[Music]
he's replacing dr matthews
he seems really nice go on he wants to
meet you
go on hurry up i'll be right here
hello jody come in
my name is nathan nathan dawkins
i thought it would be a good idea for us
to have a little chat get to know each
other a little better
that is if it's okay with you of course
jody my job is to study
strange events and then try to explain
them
like the things that happen around you
right johnny
your mother tells me you have an
invisible friend
i can understand if you don't want to
talk about it
but if you did i could help you figure
it out
this friend has he been with you a long
time
since you were born
is he a ghost or a spirit of someone who
passed away
can you draw him from me
[Applause]
mind if i take a look
so this thing is your friend
and he's connected to you with
some kind of cord
is he here right now
can you tell him to do something
[Music]
you tell him what to do and it happens
i don't tell i didn't know what to do no
one does
he's like a line in a cage we're tied
together
he can't go away that makes him really
angry
it's not my fault i want him to leave
too
it can be really scary sometimes
did he do that to you
no that was the monsters
you